it's not totally clear that the very
weak very frail cognitively struggling
joe
biden really seems to have a grasp on
the real state of our union
but he was able to slowly get through a
speech crafted by his advisors
and i am sure practiced for weeks and at
the
beginning of his remarks he thanked
himself for the 220 million covet 19
vaccinations
well maybe a nice little unifying
message to operation warp speed and
donald trump just a just a thought
joe just a nod or something medical
community medical researchers scientists
that developed it
yeah it wasn't you but take a look
anyway
after i promised we'd get 100 million
covet 19 vaccine shots
in the people's arms in 100 days we will
have provided over
220 million coveted shots in those 100
days
thanks to all the help of all of you
today ninety percent of americans
now live within five miles of a
vaccination site
everyone over the age of 16
everyone is now eligible to get
vaccinated
right now right away go get
vaccinated america go and get the
vaccination
so president unity joe biden you could
have just said
thank you president trump operation warp
speed was a tremendous success
and by the way this needs to be said you
know
all the people in that room they've been
fully vaccinated
congress they they were first in line
back in december uh
do we not have an explanation why can't
that room be
full why is everyone still wearing masks
why is there the extreme social
distancing
are these not legitimate questions i
think they are that we all deserve
answers to
joe biden these lawmakers they have been
lecturing us
encouraging us telling us that we all
need to get vaccinated for months
they told us to follow the science and
that the vaccines were incredibly
effective
and why then are they still double
masking social distancing
after getting the vaccine what kind of
message is that
sending how does that encourage
americans who might be hesitant
to get a vaccine now of course tonight
shortly after congratulating himself
on his great covert response joe then
quickly moved to address the concerns of
what is
his radical socialist base that is the
new democratic
socialist party outlining his very own
green new deal including a
fully clean green power grid
environmental
renovations for thousands of homes and
schools and buildings and
500 000 electric charging stations for
electric cars that
americans have not shown much interest
in a massive expansion of medicaid
and apparently massive new government
subsidies for wind turbines and
other forms of green energy take a look
for me when i think climate change i
think
jobs american jobs plan will put
engineers and construction workers to
work building
more energy efficient buildings and
homes think about it
there is simply no reason why the blades
for wind turbines can't be built in
pittsburgh instead of beijing
no reason none
no reason there's no reason why american
american workers can't lead the world in
the production of electric vehicles and
batteries
there is no reason no reason not to put
them in your backyard in delaware now
the logical question is
how much and who's paying for it joe
look at your screen
biden's green infrastructure investment
plan
alone costs 2.3 trillion dollars add
that to a social
social welfare plan is new covert
spending package
and we're talking about over six
trillion dollars in new spending
and you the american people you will be
covering that tab but don't take my word
for it just listen to joe take a look
how do we pay for my jobs and family
plan
i made it clear we can do without
increasing the deficits
let's start with what i will not do
i will not impose any tax increase on
people making less
than four hundred thousand dollars it's
but it's time for corporate america
and the wealthiest one percent of
americans have just begun to pay their
fair share
just their fair share people or couples
joe you keep screwing this
up we need an answer and by the way we
can do this without raising the deficit
uh probably the biggest lie from joe
biden
ever maybe right up there with the wind
blew joe over
three times as he was climbing the
stairs that's really saying something
now second of all
biden isn't just planning to raise taxes
on individuals making two hundred
thousand
yeah he screwed it up again uh but also
couples small businesses corporations
which they pass the cost on to you
when the cost of energy goes up you pay
for it
that you pay at the pump when you fill
your gas tank you feel for heating your
home
and cooling your home and by the way
uh anyone who makes any income through
capital gains
yeah that's going to go from 23 to 43
percent
and even then that's not going to be
enough mark my words
everyone that pays taxes will be forced
to pay for these massive spending bills
i say it over and over again
corporations don't pay
taxes they will pass the tax loss to you
and you will pay more for goods and for
services and for energy
all at the same time you will pay for it
let's be clear
america does not have a revenue problem
prior to the pandemic after the trump
tax cuts
yeah the federal government took in more
tax revenue
after the tax cuts than ever before in
history
we don't have a revenue problem we have
a government spending problem
and joe wants to but make it far worse
on human growth hormone and
and steroids frankly the way he's going
forward
this might even include single-payer
medicare for all
in fact tonight just a few years after
calling obamacare a big
bleeping deal you know the one that
promised uh
keep your doctor plan and save money the
one where millions lost their doctors
millions lost their plans and
we're all paying about 250 percent more
joe biden wants you to know that the
health care system is broken
well you broke it joe and just a few
months after trashing president trump's
plan to
lower prescription drug prices he's now
vowing to lower
prescription drug prices ultimately this
theme
of his speech was yeah class warfare
divide the country redistribution with
every cliche you'd expect every bumper
sticker every slogan that you could
possibly mix in
a socialist wish list any way you want
to package it
what biden presented tonight was the
failed ideal
ideology ideology philosophy of
socialism that's it
now america has a choice america is at a
crossroads
so socialism which will fail or freedom
in capitalism which would work
you have leftists authoritarianism
statism
or freedom and capitalism america you
will get to decide we are at a
crossroads
2022 is the night you begin to decide
the future of this great republic
and tonight once again it really makes
you wonder who's in charge inside the
democratic party as a matter of fact
joe doesn't even bother to show up for
his important covert 19 meetings
according to a report from real clear
politics state governors are now
increasingly frustrated
that both biden and kamala harris
routinely skip the weekly conference
calls that
are used to be coordinating the
country's covert 19 response
in his absence joe biden appointed
governor cuomo
really of new york that guy the nursing
home executive order guy
to lead our nation's coven 19 conference
calls
yeah the same andrew cuomo the one that
signed that executive action
that catastrophic policy that forced
elderly patients
infected with kova 19 out of hospitals
and back into long-term care facilities
which led to
massive outbreaks and death among new
york's
most vulnerable population the same
andrew cuomo who is now under federal
investigation for
covering up his state's true nursing
home coveted 19 death toll
and tonight according to an explosive
report from the liberal new york times
the cover-up is even worse than we
thought according to the piece cuomo's
top aides they spent
months hiding the true death toll
numbers from the general public
and even the state's own health
officials and get this quote
the actions coincided with the period
which mr cuomo was pitching and then
writing a book on the pandemic
with assistance from his top aide so is
andrew cuomo ever going to be held
accountable i
i don't know if i'd hold my breath i
wouldn't count on it apparently
he's joe's right-hand man in the fight
against covert 19. hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else